We want to continue in volume six and pick up in October the 20th, 1905.
Divine justice converts the fire of sin into the fire of chastisement.
Now, before we even think about this, we need to know that love also consumes like fire
and you find that in Hebrews 12, 29.
We're also told that the Holy Spirit is fire in Matthew 3, 11.
So the amazing thing about the Scriptures is that fire is both the image of heaven and
of hell.
In heaven is the fire of love and in hell, the fire of punishment.
And we often call trials and difficulties in the spiritual life fiery trials as well.
So Louisa says, "As I was in my usual state after I struggled very much, blessed Jesus
came for just a little, almost in the act of sending chastisements.
And he told me, 'My daughter, sin is fire.
My justice is also fire.'
Now since my justice must remain always the same, just always in its operating without
receiving any profane fire into itself.
Now profane fire is very much a biblical term, and you'll find it in Leviticus 22, 15 and
numbers 26, 61.
And people were executed for offering profane fire to God in these texts.
So divine justice is always just in the way it works without receiving any profane fire
into itself.
When the fire of sin wants to unite to God's own fire, then the divine will pause it over
the earth, converting it into fire of chastisement.
So you've heard me say this a number of times, that sin goes up from the earth and it rises
up to the heavens, but nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
So it's sent right back to us as chastisement.
I like to say that there's a post office up in heaven which stamps sin as return to sender.
So that needs a good bit of thinking about, and Jesus comes back to this subject many
times in the volumes.
So October the 24th, 1905, the miseries of human nature serve to reorder in it the order
of all virtues.
So the problems we have in our struggles, Jesus uses them to actually bring us around
and put a divine order into us.
So he brings good out of the evil that's inside of us.
While considering my misery, Louisa said, the weakness of human nature, I felt I was an
object so very abominable to myself, and I imagined how much more abominable I was in
the presence of God.
And I said to myself, Lord, how ugly human nature has become.
Now coming for just a little, Jesus told me, nothing that has come out of my hands.
There is nothing that sorry, nothing has come out of my hands, which is not good.
Now if you read Genesis chapter one, after every single thing that God made, he said,
and it was good, and when he created man, he said, and it was very good.
So Jesus is correcting the way Louisa is thinking.
On the contrary, he said, I created human nature, beautiful and striking.
And if the soul sees it as muddy, rotten, weak, abominable, et cetera, this serves human
nature like manure serves the earth.
In other words, if you see these problems, you'll do something about them.
One who does not understand what it is all about would say, this one is crazy, for he
smears the earth with this filth.
This filth means dung, but we do use dung to fertilize the earth.
It has incredible minerals in it.
And one who understands knows that the filth that is the dung serves to fecundate or fertilize
the earth and to make plants grow and to render the fruits more beautiful and tasty.
One of the lovely images that I have in my head from my time in Africa is the dung from
the elephants, and it was always wide and almost circular and flat.
And out of this, you'd get a whole crop of mushrooms, and the other animals needed the
mushrooms for food, and then other animals needed those animals for food, and that's
how it got into the food chain.
So the refuse from the elephant was very important for the whole ecosystem of the earth.
And so the Lord is telling us that the stuff that we would consider refuse in ourselves,
we need to learn how to recycle it and let the Lord turn it into something really good.
Now at the moment we're being really challenged as to how we can recycle plastics on the earth,
because otherwise we will destroy the earth.
But once they discover how to recycle plastics and make something decent of them, then we
get the balance back again.
And when the miseries that we have are put back into the Lord's system and they are recycled
and turned into virtues, then we're fine.
So they filth or the dung serves to fertilize the earth to make plants grow and to render
the fruits more beautiful and tasty.
That's because the right minerals have been given to them.
So I created human nature with these miseries or needs to reorder in it the order of all
virtues.
That's your recycling thing that you turn it into God's system.
Otherwise it would remain without the exercise of true virtue.
Very interesting.
In other words, your own weaknesses make you more humble.
They make you more patient, they make you more kind, they make you more understanding
of other people and so on.
Louisa said, "Then I saw in my mind human nature as though full of holes, and in these
holes there was rot and mud.
And from them branches loaded with flowers and fruits were coming out.
So I understood that everything is in the use we make even of the miseries themselves.
So we just need to remember we recycle and reuse."
So November the 2nd, 1905, the soul must conform to the divine will.
And if she does so, Jesus makes her live of himself and in himself.
We might say live off him, that he's supplying everything.
So Louisa says, "As I was in my usual state, I was very afflicted because of the privation
of my adorable Jesus.
And I was saying, 'Ah Lord, I want nothing but you.
I find no other contentment but you alone.
And you have left me so cruelly?'
While I was saying this, he came out from within my interior and he told me, 'Ah, it
is so.
Is it so?'
I alone am your contentment.
And I find all my contentment in you."
Now this is what Jesus is saying is if he finds one person who truly really loves him
and wants him, he gives everything to that person.
And so you're looking at the value of one.
We've had plenty of opportunity in the 20th century to see the value of one Padre Pio,
of one Mother Teresa of Calcutta, of one Louisa picaretta, of one Maria Valtarta and so on.
And there are others and he only needed one of them.
He didn't need hundreds of them and he was able to do so much with that one person because
that one person was completely given to him.
So even if I had nothing else, Jesus said, 'You would render me happy.'
My daughter, a little bit of patience until the wars begin.
Now this is 1905 and the wars are 1914 to 18, World War I.
So a little bit of patience is going to go on from 1905 to 1914.
This is the Lord's sense of humor.
And then we will place ourselves in order as before.
And Louisa said, 'And I, without knowing myself what I was saying, I said, 'Lord, let
them begin,' that's because she wants to get back into a normal relationship with Jesus.
But immediately I added, 'Lord, I was wrong.'
And he said, 'Your will must be mine.
You must want nothing, not even a holy thing, if it's not conformed to my will.'
Now there you have the essence of living in the divine will.
You don't decide whether wars should begin or wars should stop or someone be healed or
not healed or anything else, you live in the center of the divine will and whatever.
The divine will once, that's it.
That's the standard.
It's the only standard.
And we have to live out of that and we have to live within it.
And therefore, more and more and more, we find ourselves agreeing with what God does.
Well we don't tell him what to do.
Jesus said, 'In the circle of my will, do what I want you, do what I want you to go
around always, without going out of it for one instance.'
It's the English is difficult here.
So that I may render you the master of my very self.
He says, 'I want you to go around all the time in the divine will.'
That's doing all her acts and her rounds and everything.
And I will make you master of my very self and that's a thought that is quite impossible
for us to actually take on board.
That if we're actually operating within the divine will completely and totally and only
going around the divine will, only wanting the divine will, he says, 'You're even master
of me, of God.'
So I want the war, you too, and with the soul who comports herself in this way, I make of
my being a circle around her in such a way as to make her live from me or of me.
So draw a little black spot and put a circle around it and put, 'I'm the black spot.'
And then that circle is the divine will and it's me, in God, operating in him and out
of him.
And with that put Galatians 220, 'I no longer live, but Christ lives in me.'
So November the 6th, 1905, in his pains, the purpose of Jesus was primarily that of satisfying
the Father in everything and for everyone and then the redemption of souls.
It's very interesting to see his priority there was the glory of God and then the redemption
of souls.
When we're praying we usually have it upside down, that we're looking for something for
ourselves and if God gets a bit of glory out of it will then that's fine too.
So we have reparation then redemption.
So in our operating in the kingdom we must all the time be making reparation through
with and in Jesus in the divine will for the redemption of humanity.
First of all for the glory of God to fill the voids of God's glory and then for the
redemption of humanity.
So while thinking about the passion of our Lord, I said to myself how I would like to
enter into the interior of Jesus Christ and this was her very special grace that she received,
that she was the only saint who got insight into the interior passion of Jesus.
All others knew the exterior passion.
So I would like to enter the interior of Jesus Christ to be able to see everything he did
and to see what was most pleasing to his heart.
Why?
So that I too may do it and mitigate his pains by offering him what pleased him the most.
Okay.
So if you put John 519, whatever the Father does, the Son does as well.
And so Louisa says whatever Jesus does, I want to do as well.
Now that is the perfect response to Jesus.
While I was saying this, moving in my interior, blessed Jesus told me, my daughter, my interior
was occupied with those pains primarily to satisfy my dear father in everything that's
to make up for the glory of God and all the incredible voids that we had left in it.
And for everyone, he was doing that.
And then the redemption of souls.
So put Hebrews 12 to that for the joy that was before him, he endured the cross despising
the shame.
The thing that pleased my heart the most was to see the satisfaction that the Father showed
to me in seeing me suffer so much for love of him.
So don't misunderstand the Father.
The Father wasn't enjoying his son's sufferings.
What he was enjoying was the fact that someone loved him to the ultimate limits to the very
summit of love, so that love was stronger than death as you read in the Song of Songs
chapter 8.
So the thing that pleased my heart the most was to see the satisfaction that the Father
showed to me and in seeing me suffer so much for love of him.
In such a way that he gathered everything within himself, not even a breath or a sigh
it was dispersed, but he gathered everything in order to be satisfied and to show me his
satisfaction.
And I was so satisfied with this.
We would say I was so happy with it or pleased with it, that if I had nothing else, the soul
satisfaction of the Father was enough for me to be satisfied in what I suffered.
While on the other hand, much, much of my passion was dispersed on the part of human
creatures.
In other words, that we did not in fact benefit from what he did for us, because we won't
enter into it and we won't take it to ourselves.
And the satisfaction of the Father was so great that he poured in terence the treasures
of his divinity into my humanity.
Okay.
Therefore, accompany my passion in this way for you will give me much pleasure for the
same reason that somebody truly, truly loves God.
So again, what the references from John's Gospel, John 5, 36, 38 and so on to as far
as John 14, 31, I've given you those references many times.
So November the 8th, 1905, the first step to enter the will of God is resignation.
Now Jesus has been telling us this all the time since volume one.
The soul who is resigned to the divine will comes to make of God her favorite food.
And that is that we draw all our life and strength and everything from God.
So this section now is going to talk about the power of resignation and what it does for
us.
After I struggled very much, he came for just a little and told me, my daughter, it happens
to the soul who resigns herself in my will as to someone who drawing near a beautiful
food in order to see it feels the desire to eat it.
And his desire is so excited, he begins enjoying that food and transmuted into his own flesh
and blood.
In other words, that food becomes part of himself.
Had he not seen that beautiful food the desire would not have come because the eyes are the
windows of the soul and what the eye sees then the soul actually wants.
He could not have experienced the taste and he would have continued to remain on an empty
stomach.
Now, that is the way resignation is for the soul.
As she resigns herself, in the very act of resigning, she sees a divine light.
And this light dispels what prevents her from seeing God.
In other words, the resignation really opens up the eyes of the soul to see God.
And as she sees God she desires to enjoy him and while she enjoys him she feels as if she
were eating him, that is feeding on him, in such a way as to feel God himself all transmuted
into herself.
So the resignation on our part opens up the treasures of the divine will to come to us.
Therefore, it follows that the first step is to resign oneself but it is not the only
step, it is only the first one.
The second step is to desire to do the will of God in everything.
Now, for us who are trying to live the divine will, this is absolutely essential that we
desire to do God's will in everything.
The third step is to make of it one's favorite food.
In other words, it is your daily life.
The fourth one is to consume the will of God within one's own.
But if one does not take the first step, then the rest of it doesn't work.
So notice that there's nothing automatic about living in the divine will.
You have to actually want it.
Resign yourself to the divine will, desire to do the divine will, make it your daily lifestyle
and habit and let the divine will consume everything that's human in us.
So December the 12th, 1905, the word of God is a fertile word which makes virtues germinate.
Continuing in my usual state, Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus came for just a little and
he told me, 'My daughter, when a person does good, a light begins from her which goes to
her creator and this light gives glory to the creator of light, that's Genesis 1, 2,
let there be light and there was light.'
So it gives glory to the creator of light and embellishes the soul with the divine beauty.
Louisa said, 'Then I saw the confessor making the book written by me in order to read it
and together with him was our Lord saying, 'My word is rain.
That is Isaiah 55, 11, rain that falls upon the earth to fertilize it and give it life.'
My word is rain and since the rain fertilizes the earth, the sign to know whether what is
written in this book, the rain of my word, is to find out does it actually in fact give
life, does it fertilize and does it make virtues germinate.
Now notice that Jesus is claiming that what we're reading in the 36 volumes is his word.
He's not saying that it is Louisa's word, he's saying it is his word and it has the
value of his word, which is an incredible thing for us to read here.
But it also should make us confident in living this life that the Lord is asking of us.
So December the 15th, 1905, Jesus wanted to be crucified and lifted up on the cross
so that if they want him, souls can find him.
Even the heading here is extremely important.
In other words, Jesus decided to pay such an unbelievable price for our redemption so
that if I can use our modern language, the supermarket is full of food and you can come
anytime you like and get it.
The problem is some people are not hungry for Jesus.
Continuing in my usual state, Louisa said, 'I was thinking about the Passion of Blessed
Jesus and he, making himself seen crucified, shared with me a little bit of his pains,
telling me, my daughter, I wanted to be crucified and lifted up.'
That's John 12, 32.
'I wanted to be crucified and lifted up on the cross so that if they want me, souls
may find me.'
That's Jeremiah 29, 11, 'If you seek me with all your heart, I will let you find me.'
So someone who wants me as a teacher, for he feels the necessity to be instructed, I
lower myself to teach him both in the small things and in the things most sublime, such
as to make of him the most learned.
That's Deuteronomy 32, 15.
The Lord alone was his guide.
Another moans in abandonment and oblivion and he would like to find a father who comes
to the foot of my cross and I make myself father to him, giving him a home in my wounds,
my blood to drink my flesh as food in the Holy Eucharist and my very kingdom as his inheritance.
Another one is infirm and he finds me as a doctor who not only heals him but gives him
the sure remedies in order not to fall again into his infirmities.
Another one again is oppressed by calumnese and scorns and at the foot of the cross he
finds his defender to the point of rendering calumnese and scorns back to him as divine
honors and so with all the rest.
So whoever wants me as judge finds me as judge, now this is in Matthew chapter 5.
If you want him as judge you'll find him as judge, if you want him as savor you'll find
him as savor.
If you want him as friend and lover he will be friend and lover, whatever you want he
will give.
So whoever wants me as judge finds me as judge, whoever wants me as friend or spouse
or advocate or priest that's the way they will find me.
This is why I wanted to be nailed hands and feet to oppose nothing of what they want,
to make myself as they want me.
That's a very frightening image that Jesus loved us to the point of making himself whatever
we wanted.
We have to find out what do we want and reach out to him to receive life.
But woe to those who's seeing that I am unable to move even one finger dare to offend me.
While he was saying this I said Lord who are those that offend you the most?
And he added those who make me suffer the most are the religious who living in my humanity
torment and lacerate my flesh within my very humanity.
In other words these people have taken vows and they are living in a religious context
and they're saying prayers and doing religious things all the time.
So they're in a position where they can wound him more than somebody who's far away.
The one who lives outside of my humanity lacerates me from afar.
Now if somebody throws a stone at you from quite a distance it's not going to hurt as
much as someone who throws a stone from a very short range.
So January the 6th 1906 prayer is music to the hearing of Jesus especially if it is a
soul who is conformed to the divine will.
Continuing in my usual state my blessed Jesus came for just a little.
And while I was praying clasping my whole being he told me my daughter prayer is music
to my ears especially when a soul is all conformed to my will.
In such a way that nothing can be seen in her interior but a continuous attitude of life
towards the divine will.
In other words that she's living continuously in the divine will.
With this soul it is as if another god would come out and play the music for me.
That's Sam 8.
Sam 82 verse 6 I said to our gods all of you sons of the most time.
And Sam 8 says Lord even though we are nothing you've made us little less than the god and
crowned us with glory and honor.
So that's Sam 82 verse 6 and Sam 8.
So why would he say that it was like as if another god came out of us and that is that
the divine will is the essence of God.
And if we are living the divine will it means God is living in us.
Oh how delightful it is Jesus said to find one who matches me and can render me divine
honors because when we love him in the divine will we love him divinely.
When we adore him in the divine will we adore him divinely.
When we pray to him in the divine will in any way we are praying divinely.
Only one who lives in my will can reach such a point because all other souls even if they
did and prayed much would always give me things and prayers that are human and therefore limited
and small they're not divine therefore they do not have the power and that attraction over
my hearing naturally enough because it's not at his own level.
So January the 14th 1906 Jesus forms his image in the light that comes out of the soul.
As I was in my usual state Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus came for just a little and he told me
my daughter I am not content when only glimmers of light come out of the soul.
I want that her thought be light that her word be light that her desire be light that
her works be light and that her steps be light and that these lights united together form
a sun so that in this sun my entire image may be formed.
So I want to give you two references there Sam 104 verse 2 wrapped in a robe of light
and secondly Romans 829 we are made and conformed into the image of Christ himself.
This happens when she does everything for me then she becomes all light in other words
that we become spiritualised and are able to operate at the level of the divine light.
We have left behind the darkness of sin, the darkness of selfishness, the darkness of
worldliness, the darkness of human miseries and we have allowed the Lord to bring us and
transform us completely into light.
And just as one who wants to enter into the solar light finds no obstacle in entering
it so do I find no obstacle in this sun which this person has made of her whole being.
On the other hand the one who is not all light I find many hindrances in forming my image.
Okay.
So let me give you a number of references in the New Testament where we're told to walk
in the light.
It's just that we didn't understand reading the text of the New Testament just the level
that we were required to walk in.
So 1 Peter 2 9 1 John 1 7 Colossians 1 12 1 Thessalonians 5 5 and Ephesians 5 8 walk
as children of the light.
Now you know already that God is light that's 1 John 1 5.
So this is a transformation into God and that's why the Lord said that somebody who is allowing
this transformation it's like as if God came out of them.
Okay.
So the final text in Volume 6 is January the 16th 1906.
No one can resist the truth.
Anyone who lives in the sphere of the divine will resides in the abode of all riches.
Louisa says continuing in my usual state my blessed Jesus came for a little and he told
me no one can resist the truth nor can man say that it is not the truth.
As evil and stupid as one might be he cannot say that white is black and black is white.
But light is darkness and darkness is light.
Only one who loves it embraces it and puts it to work.
So while you have to admit that night is nice and day is day morning is morning and evening
is evening these are just very basic truths.
It's quite another matter to love the truth that the Lord has revealed to us in his holy
word and to put it into practice.
One who does not love remains disturbed and they are not recollected in grace and in God.
So Jesus then disappeared in a flash and he came back a little later and said my daughter
one who lives in the sphere of my will resides in the abode of all riches because God has
everything God is everything God has produced everything and he alone has the fullness of
light and beauty and grace and glory and happiness and love and everything else.
And it's only in him that we can drink the torrents of delight that Sam thirty six verses
nine and ten.
One who resides outside of this fear of my will resides in the abode of all miseries
okay so we're back to earth and all the deficiencies of earth.
This is why it is said in the gospel that one who has will be given more and one who
has not will be deprived of even that which he has.
That's Mark chapter four verses twenty four and twenty five now the reason why this is
given to us is that the Lord gives us a certain amount of faith if you use it it will grow.
That means then you have more faith to work with than you had before and when you use
that it will grow again and your faith will keep growing until you have more faith than
you will ever need you have loads to give to other people.
You start off with a certain amount of love and when you use that love that to grows and
it keeps growing as you love and you end up as Jesus says in John what is it John seven
I think it is thirty seven to thirty nine no it's not John seven.
Anyway Jesus says that out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water now that
living water is the faith and the love and the graciousness and the life that you can
give to other people because you have more than enough for yourself okay.
He says in fact since one who lives in my will resides in the abode of all riches it's
no wonder that he will continue to be enriched more and more with all goods.
The reason is that he lives in me and as though in his own house that's John fourteen twenty
to twenty one and keeping him in me would I perhaps be stingy would I not keep giving
him day after day one favor and then another never ceasing to give to him until I have shared
all my goods with him yes indeed on the other hand for one who lives in the abode of miseries
outside of my will his own will is already in itself the greatest of miseries and the
destroyer of every good as we say you are you become your own worst enemy.
So if he has a little bit of good not having contact with my will and appearing as useless
in that soul what is the wonder if it's taken away from him.
So in other words a gift and a grace which is not used is not wasted on you and so we
have to come to the realization that while the Lord is incredibly generous he is also
very wise and if he sees that we won't take the gifts that he has given to us and we won't
use them and we won't let them grow well then he is not going to waste his time his
energy on us because our decision has been made and our decision is against the will
of God as long as the decision is against the will of God we're in the miseries and
we're in the poverty. Now that's the end of volume 6 and we leave it there.